how is screenplay structure different
from outlining a screenplay oh i
actually don't think it's different at
all
your structure should be there from the
beginning and if you're outlining from
the beginning you should be able to
follow your structure there
to me the biggest difference is in my
opinion i look at a beat sheet like
one-liners of your biggest moments
and then i look at an outline of
fleshing that out so that now you know
exactly what's happening in every single
scene
not necessarily just those big beats
even though for some people that's all
they need but now you start to see the
connecting beats that get you from the
large beats to the next large beats and
then the screenplay is actually the
creative part of writing out the scene
right so that's how i explain it to my
students
some people don't make beat sheets some
people just make outlines some people
don't make outlines and they just make
beat sheets and some people just write
the screenplay you have to figure out
what's best for your process in my
opinion you want to do some work before
you get to that screenplay because the
white page is intimidating
and if you don't know where you're going
it will eat you alive
right so just like with your google maps
you got to put in the address and know
what you're following even if you decide
okay i'm going to shut it off now i kind
of know where i'm going i don't have to
keep looking at my gps great same thing
for your beat sheet or your outline
so for me i usually use the pixar
formula as my beat sheet
i love the pixar formula if you're
looking for one you can go google it now
i've added some things to my pixar
formula for my students because there's
some more emotional work i want them to
do uh before they you know get past this
point but basically it asks you about
the beat sheets not the beat sheets the
big beats uh starting at once upon a
time and um now you have this
layout of what your story is that you
can post next to your computer or
wherever it is you want to put it so
that you always know where you're going
because as creatives we will veer off
the road and that's how we end up with
uncle such and such a story that never
makes it back to where it's supposed to
be
so if you have your
outline or your b sheet or your pixar
formula or whatever it is that you're
using you always have something to come
back to to go oh yeah because you also
have you know another uncle who's like
where was i what part was i on blah blah
blah blah well now you don't have to ask
anyone it's right here you've written it
down you know where you're going and
because every scene is supposed to be
cause and effect what happens in this
scene is because of what happened in
that scene then
looking at that beat sheet lets you know
these are the scenes that i need to get
to the next beat
and these are the scenes that i need to
get to the next beat because you know
that the point is i need to get from a
to b to c to d to e you know whatever
for some people they only need to know a
g
m and z
right
i need to know a through z so my
outlines are a long you know my outlines
can be 60 pages long if i'm writing a
feature and if it's like i did one um
and i want to say it was somewhere
between 30 and 50 pages long because it
was a feature and it was science fiction
so there was a lot of stuff and rules
that you have to figure out if you don't
know the answers to those questions you
don't want to get to the page because
then you can kind of get lost in the
sauce but you know some people don't
need everything written out i like it
all to be written out because i also do
my revising in the outline
so as i start writing the screenplay and
new things do come because the outline
doesn't have to make it's not in
concrete right so new things do come oh
that's great that's good what you now
have to realize though is that new thing
is going to affect
the outline what's coming next maybe
what came before it so now you can go
back to the outline and go okay i got
this new thing so let me move this copy
and paste move that around blah blah
blah and now you can see what the new
story looks like without having to do it
in the screenplay which takes a lot
longer believe me i've done it right so
i utilize my outline throughout the
entire process which is why it's so much
longer but back to your original
question the structure is there that's
why you're outlining structure needs to
be there if you're outlining and there
is no structure your screenplay won't
have any structure
so the outline tells you what you know
and what you don't know if you're
outlining correctly i'm actually in the
middle of teaching my outlining class
right now it's called idea to story 2.0
i have it online for people to purchase
to do it at their own pace but then i do
it once a year where you get me live and
so we're now going through all of those
moments because i feel that if you have
a an effective outline then you will
write your screenplay far more
efficiently and so i give them workbooks
and worksheets that they can do
throughout that they can do with any
project they're doing but mostly so they
can eventually figure out what their
process is because they all may decide i
don't need this worksheet i don't need
that i don't need to do this outline but
if i do this thing this is the thing
that i need that helps everything to
open up so i'm just trying to help them
to figure out what their process is
while teaching them structure and then
hoping that they decide to do outlines
forever but they may not
so that's kind of a go uh go at your own
pace you said i have two two characters
right so the first idea of the story is
go at your own pace um you get all of
the videos all of the worksheets et
cetera and you can just watch them on
your own and you know figure it out as
you go and if you have any questions
then you can sign up for kind of like an
office hour thing with me and then i'll
kind of talk you through your homework
if you sign up for the live version
which i only do once a year then we
spend
two or three hours of lecture every week
and then 45 minutes to an hour of just
one-on-one talking about your story
because
if you take a screenwriting class a lot
of the times you're in taking the
general information but you're not
translating it to your story
so the only way that i know that they
actually learned what social proof was
is if i start talking to them about
their characters and social proof i only
know if they really understand an
inciting incident if i'm talking to them
about their inciting incident and what
information we got in during the normal
before the inciting incident so on and
so forth and so i think people enjoy
that part because then they start to
realize oh yeah i don't i don't know
right and it's like yeah so you can't go
to the blank page yet because you don't
know but learning that you don't know is
just as helpful because now you know
what holes need to be filled before you
get to the page when a writer is
outlining a screenplay does that mean
they are creating structure at the same
time yes exactly that's exactly what
that means they should be looking to
understand what scenes make up my normal
and when i say normal that means the
everyday life of these characters
whether the cameras showed up or not
like we're all living our normal lives
every day so your characters are people
who are doing whatever it is they do
for an action film that means we're
probably going to open
in action because in their normal lives
they're already a police officer
firefighter ex-military whatever it is
they are right
um
so now you're asking yourself in the
outline what scenes am i using to show
my character's normal life right until
we get to the inciting incident which is
the thing that's going to crash into
that normal life create change therefore
causing a goal or a problem so you have
to ask yourself what do those scenes
look like what's that sequence of the
inciting incident what is the inciting
incident how does it make my protagonist
feel you know all of these great
questions and then you're going to start
to figure out well what is the debate
is there a debate do they have to decide
to go on this journey or is it so urgent
that no matter what they're going on the
journey then you have to fix so you have
to figure out what do those scenes look
like right because you know that that
there being a debate
what's the debate who are they debating
with where are they debating why are
they debating right you get to figure
all of that out so the same is true
throughout the entire screenplay but in
the outline you're putting in all of the
structure all of those big beats but
asking yourself what are the scenes how
do i visually show this beat because a
million people can probably tell you the
inciting incident is a car crash
great where were they going what were
they doing who else is in the car where
did the car crash happen you know did
the ambulance come or did they stay
there by themselves and you know pass
away or did you know they end up getting
out did random people on the side of the
road come pull them out like what is the
scene
right and so in the outline you get to
start asking yourself what those scenes
are and putting them down not in um
you know uh screenplay format you know
but just the information of
they were driving their child to the
nursery when they got hit by a a semi
autumn uh semi truck whatever that came
through the light
and
then we cut to the jaws of life getting
them out
that's the information you need in your
outline so that when you get to your
screenplay you can write it all
beautifully you know however it is
you're going to write it well if we take
something maybe that's less dramatic so
if we go back to our our
um sort of metaphorical pam character
who's like this office administrator
everybody needs her now she's remote
working
her phone is buzzing all the time she
has no separation between her job and
her life
but then maybe the inciting incident
because she's going to find this other
job which she'll moonlight
during office hours and they won't know
it because she'll have a second computer
maybe she meets a woman in a store
and they just have a fun exchange
talking and she says
what do you do and she says oh i'm you
know an office administrator and the
other woman does these surveys right and
she's kind of fascinating there's
something a little interesting about her
so she goes hey give me your email and
all so then maybe that's where
and she sees this woman and she's kind
of intrigued by her because she she's
just different pam always does the right
thing and this woman's a little bit
rebellious a little bit interesting and
maybe that's the the incident yeah it's
not the jaws of life
but it's something yeah something is
changing her normal her normal is i'm
working at home from zoom every single
day i'm answering the calls and i gotta
get dressed from here up so that i can
be present when they need me blah blah
blah blah today for lunch i decided to
go for a walk
and while i'm on that walk because i go
into the store to buy my lunch or
whatever i meet this person
that person just changed her life
so that's the inciting incident and that
small information is what's in your
outline
then you'll flesh that out to actually
be you know full scenes and however it
is you describe them in the action and
the dialogue and blah blah that's the
screenplay but in the outline you say
pam's working from her desk all the time
she's dressed from here on up blah blah
blah she's always answering the phone
and today she decided to go for a walk
for lunch and she bumps into
insert person right right that's what
you would have in your outline okay so
that would be the inciting incident if
it wasn't as dramatic where there was a
full act yeah the inciting incident can
be the smallest thing like comedies
don't have huge inciting incidents
romantic comedies have a breakup or
meeting the other person or you know
whatever it is but whatever that thing
is it's different
because if it's not different why am i
here i don't i'm not here to watch
people's everyday lives i have my own
life i go watch my friends lives you
know what i mean i am here because
something is changing for them and i now
need to watch them to struggle through
it grow through it whatever is going to
happen on that journey that's why i'm
here so there has to be an inciting
incident something has to come in and
make change cause problems cause a goal
that needs to be achieved